-Welcome back to
"The Tonight Show."
-Thank you so much.
It's so wonderful to be here.
-We love having you here.
But we have some
very exciting news.
You're expecting.
-I am.
-Congratulations.
-Thank you.
-That's the best news
in the world.
[ Cheers and applause ]
-Thank you.
-This is the third baby.
-Yeah.
-Third baby --
-And I think the last.
-[ Laughs ] Really?
You feeling it? Yeah.
-This one was a surprise.
-Okay.
-Yes.
No, this pregnancy happened
to me.
Yes.
[ Laughter ]
[ Rimshot ]
But -- Uh-huh.
Um, but we're thrilled.
-That's funny. Yeah.
You have two boys already.
-Two boys. Yeah.
-Cyrus is 10, and Rowan is 4.
-10 and 4.
So, it's going to be
quite a big span there.
But, yeah.
-How are they feeling
about this?
-Cyrus was sort of resigned
to it.
I mean, the worst
has already happened.
His name is Rowan.
[ Laughter ]
And yeah.
But Rowan has more to lose.
Like, he has more at stake.
And he was categorically
opposed to the idea.
He said, "Yeah, no, no.
I don't like it.
I like -- I like peace, Mama."
I was like, "You like peace?"
-"I like peace" is what he said?
-That's rich, because that dude
does not shut up.
[ Laughter ]
-You like peace?
That's so funny.
-No, he said, "When it comes
out of your tummy,
we'll give it to a family
that doesn't have a baby."
[ Audience laughs, "awws" ]
-That's a good plan.
-'Cause we're done.
-He has a good plan.
He's like, "I'm the baby, man.
I can't be a new baby."
-So, no, he was
less than thrilled.
But then we talked about
how when the baby comes out,
it's going to be pretty dumb,
doesn't know a lot.
-Yeah.
-So, you know,
it's going to need assistance
and some educating.
He kind of --
That was interesting to him.
He liked the idea of being a
sort of condescending presence.
[ Laughter ]
So, now he's a little --
a little more optimistic.
-You know, every time
that you've been pregnant,
you've been on our show.
-Okay.
-So, this is --
[ Laughter ]
-Yeah, no, no, it makes me feel
like I've always been pregnant.
-No, I meant to say,
it's good luck.
-Yeah, sure.
-And your kids --
everyone's been --
your whole family's been --
-It makes me afraid
to be booked, basically.
-[ Laughs ]
-Yeah.
-That's interesting, yeah.
But the whole family's
been on our show.
-Yeah.
-That's interesting.
-Yes, that's true.
-Yeah, it's a family affair.
-The whole brood.
That's right.
-I want to talk about
"Fleishman Is In Trouble."
Man, you've been getting
great reviews for this.
Congratulations.
You got nominated
for a Golden Globe.
[ Cheers and applause ]
Critic's Choice Award.
Not too shabby.
The series is based
on a best-selling novel.
How did you hear about the book?
-Actually, my best friend
not only gave it to me,
she dragged me to the nearest
bookstore, bought it for me,
shoved it in my bag, and said,
"You have to read this book
'cause I need to talk to you
about the ending."
Okay.
-Yeah.
And actually,
I was going to do reshoots
on another limited series I did
called "The Essex Serpent,"
which took place
in the Victorian era.
And that was in my set bag
because I, like, you know,
had this assignment
from my bestie.
-Yeah, you had to read the book.
-Yeah, so I was, like,
in a corset
and surrounded
by this Victorian environment.
-We have a photo.
-Yeah.
-We have a photo
of you reading the book.
-And I was reading the book.
And, you know --
-Here's you on set.
-And then I got the offer that
week to play Rachel Fleishman.
I know. Isn't that weird?
So, yeah.
-So you're reading it here,
and then you get the offer
to be the person
in this book you're reading.
-Yeah!
-That's magic.
-Isn't that funny?
[ Cheers and applause ]
-That's magic!
-I know. I know.
-It's a fantastic book.
-Oh, it is. It's great.
It's great.
And I did finally
get to the end, and yeah.
-Yeah.
-And so --
Taffy is talented.
-She's wonderful.
She's a dear friend
and she's very gifted,
and, yeah, she wrote
a great character
that I was very fortunate
to play.
-But you and Jesse Eisenberg
play a married couple
going through a divorce.
-A hard time, yeah.
-He was on the show
pretty recently.
And was telling me a story that
he met you years ago at a party
and thought
that he found his soulmate.
-Uh-huh.
-And told his now wife,
but it was his girlfriend
who was at the party with him,
which is hilarious.
I think he said
he was stoned or something.
And he went up to you,
and he's like,
"I think I just found someone,
my soulmate."
And she goes, "That's
Claire Danes. Good luck."
[ Laughter ]
She actually said that
to him, yeah.
Do you remember
this meeting at all?
-I did not remember
the meeting.
Yeah. No.
He told me that.
There was a cast dinner,
and he said,
do you remember meeting --
No.
But -- But I love Jesse
very much
and was thrilled that he found
such a strong connection
in our introduction.
But no.
I really did have the dreamiest
time divorcing him.
He's wonderful.
[ Laughter ]
I did. I know.
-That's a great way to put it.
You guys -- What goes behind
when you're doing a role
where you have to get divorced?
-Well, we didn't have
that much time to rehearse,
so it was fairly dense
and sort of accelerated.
But our directors, John and Val,
who ironically are
a very happily married couple,
put together
some exercises for us.
So, we did some
journaling together.
We sat in our respective
bean bags, curiously.
That seemed important.
And we were given prompts,
we were asked questions,
and we had, like,
two minutes to answer them.
And then we read them
to each other --
like, what initially
attracted us to each other,
why we're disappointed
in each other now.
Just mildly uncomfortable,
but also very annoying,
because he's a very gifted
professional writer as well.
-Jesse, yeah, yeah, yeah.
-Yeah.
So, wrote these very articulate,
kind of poetic musings
about our characters' history.
And I just had words
to offer up.
-You're like, "Hey, Jesse,
dial it down a little bit.
Come on,
this isn't the part here."
Yeah.
-Yeah.
So, he won that game.
But then we played dodgeball
too, which was surprising.
-Really?
-And I did not wear
the right footwear.
-Did you know you were
playing Dodgeball?
-No! Nobody said that.
-When was the last time
you played dodgeball?
-Fifth grade.
[ Laughter ]
-Yeah, probably, yeah.
-Yeah.
I was wearing clogs,
which I don't recommend.
-[ Laughs ]
-But I think I did win that one.
-Ooh!
[ Cheers and applause ]
There's one scene
that went viral.
Your character's
at a yoga retreat,
and you're asked to do
a primal scream.
-Yeah.
-And man, oh, man, Claire Danes,
you went for it, bud.
You went for it.
And it went viral all over
the Internet the next day.
[ Cheers and applause ]
How did you pull off the scream?
-Well, I'm not, like,
formally trained.
I work in the television,
not the theater.
-Uh-huh.
-So I was worried that I was
gonna blow my voice out.
But John and Val
were aware of the risk.
And so, yeah, we ended up
doing one take.
But I was kind of surprised
that I had all that breath.
It just kept...going,
the scream.
After a while,
I was just sort of observing it.
-Yeah. [ Laughs ]
-I felt like
I was riding this wave.
-It must feel good to just
do that and just get it out.
-It was great. I recommend it.
-Yeah.
-For anyone who hasn't seen
the series yet,
how do you explain
what it's about?
-It's about a New York
middle-aged couple
who are going through a divorce.
The story's told
by the husband's,
kind of, college-aged friend.
And it broadens out,
and suddenly,
there are many
middle-aged New Yorkers
going through various
crises of their own.
-It's fantastic.
I want to show a clip.
Here's Claire Danes
in "Fleishman Is In Trouble."
Take a look at this.
-I-I haven't been
drinking coffee, so --
-What is going on?
-God, there are so many
parts to this.
-Rachel.
-I-I also have all this tea.
It might be easier.
I, um, I bought all this tea
'cause I was having
a hard time sleeping.
But all it did was just keep me
in the bathroom all night.
I feel like I-I don't know
where my toaster is,
but -- but I do have some bread.
-Rachel.
-[ Crying ]
I want to be honest with you.
I don't think I-I can
make you coffee right now.
-Oh, come on.
[ Cheers and applause ]
Claire Danes,
you're unbelievable.
The FX series
"Fleishman Is In Trouble"
is streaming now on Hulu.
Roman Reigns joins us next.
Stick around, everybody.